[Music]
there are still thousands of afghans
trying to fight to get into an airfield
to escape the mess he made at the moment
i don't know where my wife is they are
injured or hurt i will personally hold
boris johnson and the whole of this
government to account i do think that
they have changed i think they recognize
that over the course of the last 20
years afghanistan has evolved they
recognize the fundamental role that
women have played in that evolution
how the world is easy believe them
already that they have changed they're
the same people already in kabul you see
no sign of any woman
[Music]
welcome to a week in interviews this
week saw the taliban take over
afghanistan in this special program we
will bring you some of the best
interviews from across sky news as it
happened
a 20-year war which cost the lives of
thousands seemed to be won overnight as
taliban fighters advanced through the
country at lightning speed
the world watched as the capital kabul
fell on sunday sealing taliban control
and signalling a new era for afghanistan
our chief correspondent stuart ramsey
was there when it happened
[Music]
i hear a lot of shouting
coming down the road behind me in fact
it is a
i think it's a procession of uh the
taliban
today back in the white house president
biden faced the biggest test of his
presidency there was never a good time
to withdraw
u.s forces
i stand squarely behind my decision
this is a taliban press conference their
leadership is trying to convince the
world that they are new taliban
we assure the people of kabul that there
will be no excesses against them and
they will live in peace
parliament were called to ask what went
wrong and how might the uk try to put
some of it right
the prime minister's view mission at
least partly accomplished the united
kingdom amongst others joined america in
going into afghanistan on a mission to
extirpate al qaeda and we succeeded in
that core mission but mps here see
failure
this doesn't need to be defeat
but at the moment
[Music]
let's now speak to penn farving he is
the founder of the nazad charity which
operates out of kabul um it's an animal
charity he is an ngo and they've been
operating in afghanistan and are trying
to get
uh their staff and supporters out of the
country um penn can you hear us
yes
pen it's good to speak to you this
afternoon talk to me about what's
happening now your wife and some of your
colleagues have headed to kabul airport
what happened next
my wife and my country manager who is 34
weeks pregnant
they were told by the evacuation teams
that they need to get to kabul airport
within the next hour
to get their flights their evacuation
flights out
there is no security on the outside of
kabul airport and as a royal marine
commando i am absolutely furious with
these soldiers because they refuse
to go out of that camp to rescue those
people
who get them inside the safety of kabul
airfield there are still thousands of
afghans
trying to fight to get into an airfield
to get on an airplane to escape the mess
we made at the moment i don't know where
my wife is they had to finally they
managed to pull out my
um country manager to get her out for
crushed along with her one in your one
and a half year old son
somebody needs to get a grip if they are
injured or hurt i will personally hold
boris johnson and the whole of this
government to account this is a
masterclass an absolute master class in
how to do everything wrong in a
withdrawal from a country that we have
completely messed up
we cannot get to kabul airport
outside of that brim attack the taliban
now control everything there are
thousands of thousands of desperate
afghans who are trying to get into an
airport and then in between you've got
the state department or you've got the
foreign officer saying please make your
way to the airport and when you get here
then you can get a flight out well we
can't get to the airport forest johnson
and when we do the soldiers you sense
refuse to open the gate to let expats
who have been told to be there and one
of them a 34-week pregnant woman with a
one and a half year old child
they left them in a crush
i am beyond furious
this government along with joe biden
have created an absolutely unimaginable
horror show of withdrawal from
afghanistan and somebody is going to die
because there is no control
outside of that airport
we can cross to live to doha where we
can speak to the taliban negotiator and
media spokesman sahil shaheen
and we know that you've given
reassurances to women that they can
continue education um
how how much education will women be
able to have will they be able to stay
in school past the age of 12 will they
be able to go to university
yes
they can get education from priory to
higher education that means university
yes
this we have
announced this policy
not once in international
conferences like in the moscow
conference here in doha conference
this we
mentioned in our our leaders mentioned
in
their speeches
so this is our policy britain and the us
did appear to be
very surprised at how quickly you were
able to take over
why do you think you face such little
resistance
because
we had
people support
because
the kabul administration was corrupt
because those who were running
the government they there was a gap
between them their military forces
between them and the people of
afghanistan
we were we are part of the people of
afghanistan what about those who will
say that the other view is that they
were just absolutely terrified of what
the taliban were like in power before
and that that is why no resistance has
been put up
because people are just too scared to
that is their narrative because always
they are not reflecting the ground
realities they are the
by these
narratives
business narratives they were trying to
mislead the the world
opinion in their favor
do you have a message for the uk prime
minister
a yogi prime minister in all leaders of
the world they should
respect
the aspiration of the people of
afghanistan
you the people of afghanistan they
fought
for their freedom
with their lives and their
equipment
and many everything they had
for the last 20 years
now they want
to open a new
we can speak to fazana ka chai an afghan
mp and women's rights activist who is
still in kabul fazala good to speak to
you this afternoon
why did you stay we've been watching
images of families heading to kabul
airport women and children who are going
to that airport for the sheer fact that
of their sex the fact that they are
women they probably haven't held
positions of power they may not have
held jobs but they are frightened
because they are women why did you
choose to stay in kabul if you believe
you're such a target
you know
it's a question that always
just
make me
emotional
not so easy to answer you know
we as a woman leader
as a young generation leader
as
as a person who people trusted
all
we we we have we have some obligations
or some responsibility toward our people
especially the woman
the young woman who believed and trust
that we are a role model or somehow a
responsible one or we can name it anyway
so
when our president just left the country
you know
what happened it broke it broke our
heart as much as the taliban entrance
you said you've only left your house a
couple of times in the last few days and
purely by the fact that you're a female
mp
you will be a target we have to be here
but as long as we are capable of doing
something for them if if i can speak
with you
that i'm afraid of and i i should be so
if i can't risk that if i can't speak to
anyone else if i can't go out if i can
share a message to all the women so what
my being in afghanistan in kabul or
being in london or being in in
frankfurt would would what would be the
difference between that and for me
myself too that i should feel a little
bit satisfied that i did i tried my
my best
chief of the defense staff general um
cynic carter who's joining us now thank
you for joining us on the program can i
pick up first of all if i may please
with what we're hearing from the for the
home secretary forgive me this morning
saying more than doubling the number of
interpreters their families and
ancillary staff that will be able to
come to the uk you must welcome that
yes i mean i think we've got a moral
obligation to those afghans who helped
us help their country so i think it's
right and proper that we should do what
we can for them ten thousand enough i
don't know i mean i think those are
often going to be political judgments
and of course a lot of it will depend
upon the feasibility of who can travel
and that the pace at which they can
travel what are you hearing about what's
happening on the ground well at the
moment i think it's very calm i think we
are collaborating with the taliban on
the ground um and that seems to be a
very straightforward relationship they
are keeping the streets of kabul very
sta very safe and indeed very calm they
are helping us at the airport um i think
we have a worrying problem potentially
with
worried afghans
trying to get into the airport again we
saw some very troubling scenes over the
weekend but providing we can keep
control around the airport perimeter
there's no reason to suppose that we
can't carry on doing what we're doing
that's going to be quite thuggish at
some of those checkpoints firing over
people's heads and the like well i think
they've also got challenges with public
order but certainly what we're not
getting are reports of um the behaving
in a sort of medieval way like you might
have seen in the past and let's see what
the taliban allow us all to do at the
moment um we're going to continue
we're going to continue to move as many
people as we possibly can given the
circumstances we've got and how do you
feel about collaborating with the enemy
when um they have carried out such
atrocities against um uk military
personnel over the years i think you
have to be very careful using the word
enemy um i think people need to
understand who the taliban actually are
and of course what they are a disparate
collection of tribes people as president
karzai put it to me only yesterday
they're country boys
and the plain fact is that they happen
to live by a code of honour and a
standard which has been their standard
for many many years it's called pashtun
wally it has honour at the heart of what
they do they are bound together by a
common purpose which is they don't like
corrupt governance they don't like
governance that is self-serving and they
want an afghanistan that is inclusive
for all so i think rather than talking
about them what except women
well again i think we have to wait and
see i mean i don't know what they mean
we can't support the way that they treat
women we surely well i think you have to
listen to what they're saying at the
moment and i think you have to listen to
the facts on the ground they're saying
they are definitely
in law yeah and i'm not saying that's
anything that you and i would approve of
particularly just but i do find that i
absolutely but i do think that they have
changed i think they recognize that over
the course of the last 20 years
afghanistan has evolved they recognize
the fundamental role that women have
played in that evolution and yes they at
the moment will undoubtedly say that
they want to respect women's rights
under islamic law and that will be a
sharia law but that doesn't necessarily
mean that they won't allow them to be
involved in government and in education
and in medicine and those things that
they need them to be involved in so i
think we have to be patient we have to
give them the space to show how they are
going to step up to the plate and
whether or not we can work with them
will very much depend upon how they
treat all afghans what does that space
look like how long do we need to wait to
see whether they've changed how many
women need to be raped how many uh girls
need to be married off at the age of 12
how many women need to be told that they
can't be educated past the university
level um none of that is appropriate of
course it's all that would be beyond the
pale but i think again i would ask you
to show the evidence where that's
happening in kabul at the moment
yeah what my question is is how long do
we need to wait how many women need to
be raped or murdered or beaten because
they go out i come back
to you
show us the evidence of that actually
happening on the ground at the moment
well as the taliban returns to
afghanistan there are fears that two
decades of progress for women could be
lost this includes access to education
and employment well nilufa rahmani
became the first female fixed-wing pilot
in the afghan air force she was granted
asylum to the u.s three years ago after
receiving threats from the taliban and
her parents and sister are still in
kabul uh well nila joins me now uh i
suppose the first question you must be
how how are your family in kabul what
contact have you been able to have with
them
well it has been definitely difficult
for them the situation is every day
getting more dangerous and everybody's
so terrified everybody's just finding a
way to get away and unfortunately
i have a difficult time reaching out my
parents i don't know if it is due to
internet or electric or
i have no idea but i am definitely
um really worried about everybody down
there it looks like people are so
terrified they're so scared nilofer tell
us a little bit about
about your journey to where you are now
i mean becoming a pilot in the afghan
air force that uh you know despite the
fact that the taliban were not in power
that must still have been
extraordinarily difficult
very difficult you know
as an afghan female
of course this is something the talibans
are against the taliban warriors against
women they don't want a woman to be
educated educated they take away the
rights from the woman the first thing
they do they take away everything from a
woman the same thing i was the symbol of
freedom of women in afghanistan as a
woman that i raised my voice and tried
to go against what they believe and
unfortunately it end up rest my life and
my family's life and i have been
threatened so many times by them my
brother got shot by them and it's it's
just
a really really scary situation for any
woman to be in could you ever see a
situation arise though where you may be
flying
for america against the taliban over
afghanistan
well
as an afghan woman that would be my
honor i would absolutely do it with not
even thinking two seconds about it i
spoke to a taliban spokesman a couple of
days ago
and he said to me that the taliban have
changed that they believe that women
should be educated he said that they
could go to university he said that
women could work he also said the women
didn't need to wear the burqa walking
around afghanistan
do you believe him
i do not
i do not believe that the people that
they already prove themselves how the
world is easy believe them already that
they have changed they're the same
people already in kabul you see no sign
of any woman
any pictures of a woman in the stores
and the walls it has been already
blacked out there's no woman in the city
one woman already got killed because she
didn't have a burka on how can i even
trust that word how the world can trust
that word
welcome back to sky news and our
continuing coverage of the crisis
unfolding in afghanistan the taliban's
takeover of the country as kabul felt
this weekend many former soldiers began
questioning whether their actions in the
country had been rendered futile for
former royal engineer jack cummings the
war was utterly life-changing he lost
both his legs and was in a coma for a
month
well he wrote this tweet on saturday as
the taliban advanced
was it worth it probably not did i lose
my legs for nothing looks like it did my
mates die in vain
yep
many emotions going through my head
anger betrayal sadness
to name a few
well jack joins me now
can you put it into words how you're
feeling watch afghanistan go back 20 30
40 years
no honestly i'm totally loss of words
totally lost the words what's happened
the past week the past couple of days
you know just
yeah the emotions are all even more so
you went over when i wrote the tweet on
saturday it was it was that as a
certainty as my anniversary it was my
anniversary and blown up as us scotty's
called your bangiversary so that day's
always raw for me anyway raw for me and
my family normally i'm quite quiet i uh
keep myself to myself you know i mean my
wife will have a few drinks and
reminisce but i just felt on saturday i
had to write something that i had to put
my two pence and just seeing events
unfolds in afghanistan just
heartbreaking and devastating to see
just the country i fought in and fought
for
has just just gone up in smoke like that
you know i'm saying my best wishes the
600 powers that have gone out and i you
know i hope they all come home safe and
sound and they bring home
as many as possible including as many
interpreters as they can get hold of you
know if anybody deserves the right to be
free and and live in peace and come to
the uk as the interpreters that helped
western forces and i i really hope they
can get as many as possible i feel sorry
for the country of afghanistan um
you know my job out there was to find
bombs to find night improvised explosive
devices i love my job
i'm so proud to have served in the
british military in the british army
do you think a presence should have
remained because the excuse that
president biden used was
we don't want a forever war
i i get that to a degree i truly do and
i'm not naive i knew we couldn't stay
here forever afghanistan and afghans got
the right to look after themselves and
govern themselves and to look after
themselves but just to see
the quick withdrawal and then it to go
up and smoke in a week or whatever it
was it just just doesn't feel right and
it that can't be right i just wonder
what you would say to
boris johnson if he's watching now
to to boris johnson um me personally was
it worth it
you know he said you know british
soldiers didn't die in vain but i don't
think he'll ever say that face to face
of a grieving mum or a grieving wife or
grieving father
um
you know i lost my legs and i will never
walk again and i'm bound to a wheelchair
for the rest of my life don't get me
wrong i knew the rest i i signed up on
the deadline and i knew the risk going
out i was proud to serve my country i
knew that but i wanted something out of
afghanistan i truly felt i was making a
difference in afghanistan every bomb
that i was finding was saying their life
these bombs don't discriminate these
ideas don't discriminate it doesn't
matter if you're a british serviceman
american or you're you're a local afghan
if you stand then it's going bang and
you're you're losing a leg you're losing
alarm you're losing your life everyone i
found was hoping to make a difference
how do the families of those who didn't
come home feel about the taliban's
takeover my next guest christine
harrison is the mother of corporal
darren bonner who was killed in helmand
in may of 2007 she feels that down and
that everything they achieved was for
nothing hello to you thank you for
joining us christine i've just been
speaking to the head of the army and he
was saying that your son's life and
those of his colleagues were not in vain
what would you say in response to him
um what i'd say i mean i would have said
that as um
going back a few months ago but i mean
i've just come to terms really with the
fact that darren's death has freed
people and that and that
it's taken me 14 years
to get to that point
um and now i just feel it was for
nothing i i don't i don't agree with
what the government is saying
um
i'm very very proud of my son don't get
me wrong i'm i love you know love him i
miss him
and
there's other families out there like me
who feel like
feel like this and heartbroken i feel
like i've been taken back 14 years
um and i'm reliving it all over again
and um
the government can't take that away
and
i'm sorry
um
other families
are in the same boat as i am and
and it was in vain
i haven't got my son
and he died i feel right now
he died for nothing
um yes i would have said he
he done everything he could i'm very
very proud of him and he was very very
proud of being part of the british army
but um
i feel so let down so let down and i
feel he's been let down as so many other
soldiers have
[Music]